Legends about the end of the world often come
with the sounds of thundering hooves, and
the approach of Four Horsemen.
War.
Famine.
Pestilence.
Death.
They will descend on the world and usher in
the end of days.
It’s a terrifying idea, these horsemen bringing
darkness and decay wherever they go, as the
world collapses all around them.
We all hope that we’ll never see the day
that the Four Horsemen come.
Unfortunately, some unlucky people out there
have already encountered their own version
of the Horsemen of the Apocalypse, shadowy
riders with inhuman strength that follow disaster,
destruction, and untold suffering.
The SCP Foundation came across a series of
journal entries written by Dave Harkand, an
infantryman in the British Expeditionary Force
during World War I. That first World War was
a nightmare for all who fought in it, a sea
of bloodshed and gunfire, young men crouched
terrified in foxholes and wondering when death
would finally come for them.
The horrors of war are notable, but not exactly
the sort of thing the SCP Foundation preoccupies
itself with.
So what was so captivating, so specifically
terrible, about Dave Harkand’s journals?
They described his experiences over the course
of The Battle of the Somme, and an anomaly
he encountered there that was unlike anything
he had ever seen.
No military training, no combat experience,
could have prepared him for what was waiting,
hiding in the fog of war.
His first journal entry began on a lighthearted
note, or as lighthearted as one can be in
the face of combat.
“June 27th, 1916
Finally arrived at the front!
I picked up this little journal while I was
in Paris, figured I might as well keep record
of my heroics on the battlefield.
Quite chuffed to finally be in action, though
it seems I'm the only one.
Most of these blokes have been fighting for
a couple months now, and they look downright
dreadful.
Mud all over the uniform, and their faces
are so pale, look like they haven't eaten
or slept for months.”
A few days later, he began to hear stirrings
amongst his fellow soldiers, and strange sounds
that rocked their barracks.
He described the first unsettling incident:
“July 2nd, 1916
Woke in the early hours of the morning.
Ground was shaking, damn near shook me out
into the muck on the dugout floor.
Poor blokes in the bunks on the other side
looked liked they had seen a ghoul.
Pair of Northern Irish lads from Kitchener’s
Armies if I remember right.
Kept muttering about a Nuckatee?...Were both
gripping a gold crucifix.
Was about to lay my head back down and get
a wink of shuteye when I ended up scrambling
into the mud.
Loudest damn thing I'd ever heard.
Thought it was the Hun Artillery bout to mark
us with a whizz-bang, only problem was, never
did get the bang.
This morning asked our brass hat about the
Artillery barrage.
Gave me a funny look, and asked what the bloody
hell I was talking about.”
The next day, Dave went searching for the
source of the loud sound.
He didn’t find any evidence of artillery,
but instead found something he had never seen
before.
It was a crater, shaped like a giant horse’s
hoof.
He brushed it off as just another oddity of
the battlefield, a bit strange but nothing
to be concerned about.
There were more important things at hand,
anyway.
The next day, he finally saw combat first-hand,
and things only got more bizarre and frightening.
“July 3rd, 1916
Huns made a push today, first time they've
moved in our region.
First time I'd ever seen combat.
It's not romantic and adventurous.
It's terrifying, and deadly.
My hands can't stop shaking, already messed
up the chit once.
The Huns had our outfit up against a wall,
damn near overran us, didn't help that it
rained the night before making our fox hole
filled to the brim with muck.
One of the Fritz came right at me…just…I
put one right between his eyes.
Fell right at the edge of the trench, and
had to look him in the eyes, poor lad couldn't
have been more than 17 or 18.
Martin, one of those Irish lads, is gone.
Was unlike anything I'd ever seen, one moment
he's standing shooting at the Huns, all of
the sudden, the mud starts boiling.
Fore anyone can react, Mud just flies everywhere,
everyone else is suddenly knocked down off
their feet.
I look up, and he’s just gone.
Wasn't even body parts left.
Haven't told anyone…but I'd swear that there
was bones coming up from underneath him right
before the mud went flying.
His mate, Brendan, was digging in the mud
for hours, looking for the crucifix.”
Martin’s body was never found, no matter
how they searched.
A little over a week later, things got even
worse.
“July 14th & 15th, 1916
Huns tried to push this morning in the rain.
I was in the machine gun nest with Brendan,
the other Irish chap in my unit.
They kept coming and coming, and getting stuck
in the mud, and I just kept shooting.
Sun is rising.
I'm on watch till 8, at least that's what
the Brasshat said.
I've started losing track of how much times
been passing.
There's something out there.
Something lurking out in the mud and dead
Huns.
Nearly dozed off last night, listening to
the moans of the blighty wounded stuck out
in No-man's land.
Poor souls got left behind.
Saw something out of the edge of my vision,
something big.
Couldn't quite make it out, it was much darker
than usual, overcast sky was obscuring the
full moon.
Heard a couple of screams, but whatever it
was, was gone before my flare hit the sky.”
This would not be Dave’s last sighting of
the large, dark figure.
This mysterious shadow would appear again,
several days later.
And there would be more of them.
“July 30th, 1916
I've been seeing them at the edge of my vision,
ever since that first night.
They're huge, but they move so damn fast that
they're gone before I can get a clear look.
Or at least, that's how it was mucking out
until today.
Thick fog and mist rolled in this morning,
blanketed everything.
We figured the Huns might use it to launch
another push.
Bastards have been pushing non-stop since
the 20th.
Saw it, through the fog, looked like a shadow,
hiding in the mist.
Some sort of Horse like creature, with a something
dragging along the ground, and a giant lump
where the rider would sit…cept the lump
started moving.
Could have sworn it was a person, or something
that looked like a person.
Sat up, and the things dragging along the
ground reached out in front of it and picked
up something, thought it was a couple dead
Jerry's…until they started squirming.
I'll never forget the noise it made.
Louder than a banshee, shrill and twisted.
It looked right at me.
Two pairs of red glowing orbs.”
Two weeks after meeting eyes with this chilling
apparition, Dave wrote a short note in his
journal:
“August 5th
Brendan calls them Nuckelavees.
Won't tell me much more than that.
Beginning to understand why all these blokes
looked so terrified when I first arrived.”
It wasn’t until another week had passed
that Dave would truly begin to understand
just what kind of monster he was up against.
Not the enemy soldiers, but something far
more horrible.
Something inhuman.
“August 13th
Bloody hell.
They're nightmares.
Been on watch two nights in a row, one just…appeared
right there, right in front of me.
20 feet, had to be at least 20 feet away.
Towered into the sky.
Got my flare to go off in time to see it pick
up a couple wounded Jerry's in the mud.
They don't have bloody skin.
There's just muscle, and fat.
The thing on its back…wasn't human, no way
could it be human.
Had no skin either, no legs, just merged straight
into the horse at the stomach.
I took a couple shots at it with my rifle…did
absolutely nothing, like I was shooting it
with a sling shot.
It stopped soon as my flare reached its highest
point, and turned.
Looked straight down at me, both the horse
and the…thing on its back.
It smiled.”
He tried to talk to his superiors, tried to
warn of the horrors he was seeing and the
danger he felt they posed, but they wouldn’t
listen.
Night after night, the creatures came back.
“August 17th 1916
Been assigned night watch the past four nights
straight.
Tried to tell the brass hat about the nuckelavees.
Didn't believe me.
Said it was the shell shock playing with my
head.
Had to put a sock in it, and keep on.
It keeps coming back.
Every night.
Same spot, 20 feet in front of me.
Picks up wounded Jerry's, turns and looks…and
then it's gone.
It's playing with me, I'm sure of it.
Last night there was another one too.
Four of those things on its back, did the
same damn thing.”
A few days later, Dave spotted something that
made his blood run cold.
“7:00 A.M.
August 20th 1916
Jerry's made a big push yesterday.
Rained two days ago, all day, so the muck
was deep.
We were on the machinegun again in the pillbox.
So many of them in no-man's land last night,
couldn't tell the dead from the living.
Haven't slept in six days.
There were five tonight.
Three of them had more than one of those…things
on their back.
The one that keeps coming back…dropped something.
Saw it shine in the flare light.
10:00 A.M.
August 20th 1916
Went out into the mud where it appears every
night.
Found Martin's crucifix and tin hat.”
Whatever this thing was, it had taken Martin.
It seemed to want Dave to know that, too.
It left behind Martin’s lost things for
him to find.
As if it was gloating.
As if it already knew that it had won.
“August 20th 1916
They're getting bold, saw one out in broad
daylight.
Pretty sure it was the same one.
Buried itself in the mud, just lying there…waiting.
We're going over the top at three.
There are more out there now…all doing the
same thing…god help us.”
Dave Harkand was declared Missing in Action
on August 20, 1916, following an attempted
counterattack against the German forces.
Another soldier from his unit, Brendan O’Malley,
was also reported Missing in Action on the
same day.
Though Dave’s body was never recovered,
his journal was found 20 feet away from the
edge of the German trenches two months later.
Poor Dave Harkand had no idea what he, and
the rest of his fellow soldiers, encountered
out there.
He didn’t live to learn more, but he came
face to face with SCP-3456.
SCP-3456 is not one being, but rather a group
of quadrupeds that vaguely resemble horses.
From a distance, their silhouette looks like
that of a horse with a human riding on its
back.
However, once the observer gets closer, they
will notice some disturbing differences.
These creatures do not look like any ordinary
horse.
They are smooth and hairless, with translucent
skin and three-toed hooves.
Anyone unfortunate enough to get close to
one of these creatures will be able to see
through their skin to the blood vessels and
muscle underneath.
They will also notice that there is no rider
perched atop the creature’s back at all.
The humanoid shape is a part of the creature’s
body, an extension of them, fused to its back.
The humanoid figure consists of a pair of
long arms, which drag along the ground as
the creature moves, and a head.
The arms end in sharpened bones rather than
fingers, and the head has mostly human features,
with the exception of a hole where the nose
should be.
The creatures vary greatly in size, with the
largest on record measuring at a height of
30 meters and a width of 15.
They appear to be invulnerable, at least when
it comes to any traditional human weaponry
they have currently been exposed to.
Gunfire, explosives, swords and arrows, and
even nuclear blasts seem to have no effect.
If you happen to get a look at one of these
bulletproof abominations in person, then I
am so sorry.
You are as good as gone.
Because once you’ve seen one of these creatures,
they have also seen you, and they will not
stop until they have taken you.
They will track you, stalk you, hide buried
in mud and nestled in bushes.
They will wait for the opportune moment, and
they will reach out with their unnaturally
long arms, smiling with no lips as their blood
red eyes burn like hellfire, and you will
disappear forever.
They will travel far beyond the site where
they first appeared, until they have finally
captured their prey.
This isn’t an SCP-096 situation, either.
They aren’t punishing you for seeing their
face.
They want to be seen, and will go out of their
way to show themselves to people until they
have captured as many as they want.
No one knows what becomes of SCP-3456’s
victims, but they are never seen again.
Though items once belonging to the missing
people may resurface, their bodies are never
found.
There is only one way to escape from SCP-3456,
and that is to find and cross a body of fresh
water.
For reasons unknown, the entities are unable
or unwilling to cross rivers, streams, and
lakes.
The Foundation first discovered this during
an operation in Iraq, in which several agents
encountered a group of SCP-3456 manifestations.
They fled from the monsters, and quickly retreated
across the Tigris river.
Once they had reached the other side, they
saw that the creatures had not followed them
onto the bridge.
Instead, they remained at the riverbank on
the other side, watching, and waiting.
This was quickly noted, and added to potential
containment procedures, though the exact reason
for SCP-3456’s dislike of fresh water is
currently unknown.
In Dave Harkland’s journals, his fellow
soldier described the creatures as “Nuckelavees,”
but would not elaborate beyond that.
So what is a Nuckelavee?
The word refers to a creature from the waters
of Orkney, a group of islands on the northern
coast of Scotland.
Their name is thought to come from an Orcadian
word meaning “Devil of the Sea,” and they
truly are like something out of hell.
These creatures are native to the ocean, and
supposedly take on another form when in their
natural habitat, but no one knows what they
truly look like.
On land, the creature is a hybrid of man and
horse, with a large snout like that of a pig,
and a single red eye that burns like the embers
of a fire.
It has no hair or skin, just raw, tissue and
bone dripping black blood.
Everything about the creature is malicious
and deadly, intended to bring harm and calamity
to humans.
Even its breath is toxic, thought to cause
disease, plague, and the death of crops.
As they are native to the ocean, they detest
fresh water, and will not cross it even in
pursuit of their prey.
They will also not appear when it is raining.
In the legends of the Nuckelavee, they do
have a natural enemy.
A creature from Orcadian folklore known as
the Mither of the Sea is said to have the
power to keep the monsters from coming ashore
during the Summer months.
The Mither, or Mother, is a benevolent force
of nature, giving warmth to the oceans and
life to the beings of the water and the land.
Though SCP-3456 has appeared during the Summer
months, it has never been spotted in the Orkney
region during this time of year.
Perhaps this is a coincidence, but some Foundation
researchers have proposed a research expedition
to the area in order to look for the kindly
ocean spirit.
So far, this proposal has been denied.
SCP-3456 is classified as Keter, and there
is currently no way to effectively contain
it.
All previous attempts to contain or to neutralize
the horsemen have failed, though the Foundation
is always looking for new methods to attempt.
Currently, any personnel who see the horsemen
will be given Class G amnestics at a treatment
center located within one kilometer of a freshwater
stream, river, or lake.
All references to the horsemen have been scrubbed
from historical records, and any sightings
are to be blamed on PTSD, shock, and trauma-induced
hysteria.
Areas that are likely to attract SCP-3456,
such as war zones and areas impacted by natural
disasters, are to be heavily monitored by
the Foundation.
In the event of a disaster, Foundation personnel
will be sent to help with evacuation in order
to get all civilians away from SCP-3456 as
quickly as possible.
So what is SCP-3456?
Is it the dreaded Nuckelavee from folktales
and whispered fireside warnings?
There are some notable differences between
the stories and what the Foundation encountered.
SCP-3456 does not seem to have come from the
ocean, nor is it limited to only appearing
around Orkney.
These beasts seem to manifest from thin air,
and disappear the same way when their nasty
work is done.
But, folklore and passing down stories often
distorts things.
Details change, and others are added or left
out.
In the original stories, the Nuckelavee was
thought to be the cause of famines, plagues,
and disasters.
Perhaps it was simply drawn to these events,
lured there by the scent of pure human misery.
Perhaps the Nuckelavee is not just similar
to SCP-3456, but the two are one and the same.
Or perhaps they are something entirely different.
Whatever the case may be, there is nothing
we can do to stop them.
War, famine, pestilence, and death are everywhere,
they are inevitable and unfortunate parts
of life on earth.
So, it seems, are these deadly riders, these
monsters that are neither horse nor man, but
still somehow both.
Every time we wage war, every time disaster
strikes, they will come to watch, to pick
through the rubble, and to smile.
Maybe, we don’t need to dread the coming
of the Horsemen of the Apocalypse.
They are already here.
Now go check out “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885
- Find Him” and “The Secret at the Bottom
of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” for more monstrous
finds from the SCP Foundation!